hey guys welcome back to the nepo sewed
of awesome bill well as you may know
this week guardians the galaxy vol 2
comes out and when the first guardians
to galaxy came out I did a tutorial on
how to build the star-lord mask and I
also did a tutorial on how to make some
cheap
star-lord guns using some dollar store
squirt guns and from dollar store
shampoo bottles and if you're interested
in seeing that tutorial you can check
the link below and it's on my personal
YouTube page but as you can see these
aren't very movie accurate so some
months back I purchased online this
star-lord gun from rubies and you can
find out a bunch of different places a
lot of different costume shops carry it
I think I'm probably got this one
through spirit usually retails for
around fifteen bucks but you might be
able to find a little bit cheaper so
we're gonna be doing today is cracking
this sucker open and just doing a quick
paint job to try and make it look like
star Lords gun here alright it's super
lightweight so I'm probably going to add
some weight to it we'll open it up and
maybe I'll put some I've got some scrap
pieces and metal and stuff like that
that we can glue to the inside to give
it a little bit of weight but that's
purely up to you if you are like now
it's fine I don't care if it's a little
light would be a nice and light to carry
around or something medic on you don't
want something weighing you down things
like the screw holes and stuff like that
we'll cover that up and I think there's
some detailing and stuff like that that
you might want to add either with the
paint job or a little bit of sculpting
maybe and we'll see alright so as I said
I'm going to I'm going to take mine
apart because I want to add some pieces
to the inside of it maybe some pieces of
metal or threaded rod I think probably
what I'm going to use right some washers
or something like that that I go and put
in there to kind of distribute the
weight a little bit and give it a little
bit more weight to it a little bit more
heft so I'm going to take the screws out
take it apart and
glue those on the inside so we're just
going to know my name's mr. some screws
already so guess that of the process of
taking it apart alright so I have my two
halves which was actually kind of more
of a panic than I thought it was going
to be I took all the screws out but it
still seemed to have maybe a little bit
of adhesive in certain areas to kind of
hold it together yeah so just be careful
when you're taking it apart not to not
to break it don't get impatient so yeah
I'm just going to be taking I have a
couple pieces of threaded rod and some
nuts here that I'm just going to be
placing into the gun and we'll glue that
into place and then put that on and then
let you give it some weight again this
is purely up to use as an extra step
that I'm taking if you are like a I
don't care if it what light weight or
anything like that then by all means
don't bother take it apart because it
was more of a pain in the neck then
probably shows us so I noticed on the
actual star-lord gun there's some little
holes or some fluting like on the side
here on the top and bottom there are
five little detailed kind of holes
whatever I'm going to go ahead and draw
it on here and drill the holes out and
kind of probably using my rotary tool or
some files kind of make those little
details on there and put a piece of
black plastic behind it so that it has
that recessed kind of area inside there
you kind of see the holes but it doesn't
go all the way through the gun again
this is another optional kind of thing
to do you could probably just paint it
um but I think it a little cooler a
little bit more authentic if yeah we
just drill those holes and do a little
filing in sanding I think it looked
pretty good
design on their Title II I think I plan
to look I will start to drill it out and
file it down I use the rotary tool
probably just drill it and with a little
bit of with a small file actually I
could probably be easier than maybe even
the rotary tool we'll see
[Music]
I'm going to finish cleaning these up a
little bit and then we'll glue the
styrene into place and then glue the
threaded rod in there can I give it some
weight and we can close it back up fill
it with putty and close up all the seams
and stuff like that clean it up and it
should be ready for painting
[Music]
I'll read it might as well put in the
threaded rod and threw that into place
hot glue
[Music]
alright sagem a piece of the plastic and
I threaded rod glued in there pretty
good pull side is going to pop them back
together up the screws back in put some
putty in the holes and start painting
[Music]
you
yeah then go ahead and start standing
down all will be screw holes there after
it's had a chance to cure
she gives me take one about five or ten
minutes or so
all right now that we've sanded all of
our parts we bondo'd just going to go
ahead and start painting do a flat black
over the whole thing
and then I think we're gonna have to
touch ups and all the metallic parts
right obviously with the metallic
[Music]
all right so after I hit it with a
several passes of the flat black I did a
few passes with a satin to kind of give
it as krylon colormaster is satin finish
to kind of give it a little bit of a
shine to it so now we're going to mask
off all the areas except for these
elements in here which are kind of a
gold color so I'm going to use the
Krylon dual superbond metallic gold and
paint up those parts and then using some
I've got some Citadel Games Workshop
modeling paints kind of old so if
they're any good that I might use that
then the kind of dirt you have some of
the elements and and give it some extra
detail and then we'll kind of muddy up
some of the real deep crevices with some
cheap acrylic paint also for all of the
chromed elements like the front and
stuff like that and the the pieces on
the side I think I'm going to use the
same technique I used in my original
build where I just use metallic tape and
kind of the same way you would put it on
to mask an area to paint just put the
apply it right on there and it's already
kind of got the grooves and stuff like
that in it that give me a good
guidelines like and put it on and kind
of very delicately with an exacto knives
cut out the pieces that I want and or
cut away the rest and leave just the
chromed elements on there and using like
a brillo pad or some steel wool or
something we can kind of duct it up a
little bit kind of give it kind of a
little bit of aware and yeah maybe even
do a dry brushing on the edge to kind of
do some of that bluing
[Music]
you
all right I'm going to use a little bit
of this to the doe skin workshop paints
here this is hash up copper just a
little bit of this to kind of mighty up
some of the areas and then creasing
stuff I'm just going to cut
a bit in the cracks there
those elements kind of pop out a little
bit more I'm going to go real heavy
because I don't want it to be too dark a
too prominent
[Music]
I'm some spots I'm gonna kind of dab it
on there and then kind of dry it off
with a paper towel
[Music]
and I'm going to take some gold and just
going to highlight
more raised element
add a little bit of name finish kind of
old days a little bit
[Music]
and so here kind of watering down and
run I'm just gonna highlight some of
these areas here just a minute it's a
metallic piece on the gun but it's a
it's a little darker so I think the
Browns kind of works well I just want to
tell lightly do it give a little bit
like it's kind of a dirty look it'll
catch a little bit of light and stuff
like that now it's good all right some
of these little rivets and stuff like
that I'm going to use a metallic
[Music]
alright that's looking pretty good
before I do any of the deeper detail and
start muddying up a little bit I want to
put the metallic tape on it and see how
that kind of looks and probably you'll
be easier to weather the whole thing
once that's on there
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so I got the tape on and you
keep kind of working it with your thumb
or a pencil or something like a
something soft you can really kind of
work out all those little creases and
stuff like that yeah I dusted the the
tip with a bit of a nickel which kind of
gives it a nice variance there it kind
of dulls the tip and I think then if we
do a little bit of dry brushing to kind
of blew it maybe just a little bit on
the edge it'll stand out a little bit
more look a little bit more prominent
so if you're good at airbrushing you
could do this a lot easier but you don't
have an airbrush and you're looking for
an alternative way to do it kind of used
to want to have that kind of look like
the laser burn kind of scorch mark on
there I think this is a fairly effective
way to do as you can see it gives it a
tint of the blue thing on how the light
hits it and depending on how dark you
want to go just add the blue and then
wipe it off leaving kind of like an edge
there along the side there so that is
like bluer kind of further in you go and
then the edge here is still very
metallic or has that kind of look where
the it's sort of like it's scorching or
it's burning the further down it goes
all right well it's about all I have
time for today but I'm pretty happy with
the way it's turning out so far I mean
you could stop there
I used the metallic tape whatever put
the pieces on the ends I think in
retrospect I might replace these all
together they're not as highly detailed
and there be easy enough I think to
sculpt the piece and place over it that
would be a little bit a little more
detail I'm sorry I didn't get to do the
handle the way I wanted to them you
could again you could stop here my idea
is to do a little heavy gloss with kind
of like a metallic gray and then using
like a mesh pattern maybe something you
find it Michaels or something like that
and I kind of held on an angle in front
of it and then do some light passes with
a flat black to give that sort of meshed
sort of pattern on there and to allow
that the glassy elements to kind of
really pop so yeah if you're interested
in doing a star-lord cosplay and you
need a relatively inexpensive gun I know
a lot of people are
3d printed versions of star-lords gun
and there are the nerf versions and
stuff but this is a pretty inexpensive
alternative so that about does it for
today but I do want to say thank you to
everybody who I met at c2e2 last week I
was really fun being there and meeting
fans and signing autographs and just
talking to people about costumes and
stuff like that there was some great
costumes and some great props and stuff
like that that people came by and showed
me and if you go to my facebook page at
James Jim Jerez you can see some of the
pictures I posted and stuff like that
from c2e2 so once again you guys Rock
thanks so much for watching and again
I'll try and have these a little bit
more frequent sorry about the long lapse
and episodes but I'm going to try and
get them out to you as quickly as I can
so yeah hope you guys enjoy guardians
the galaxy vol 2 and I'll see you next
time take care guys
[Music]